the Chinese researcher has created an
international controversy over science
and ethics after claiming he helped make
the world's first genetically edited
babies according to the Associated Press
the researcher altered embryos for seven
couples during fertility treatments one
resulted in the birth of twin girls the
claims have not been independently
verified they also were not published in
a medical journal where they could be
vetted by experts now this kind of gene
edited is been editing is banned in the
United States the changes can be passed
to future generations and could harm
other genes our dr. David agus is an
oncologist and leads the USC Westside
Cancer Center and is here to talk more
about this a lot of people in the
medical community are buzzing about this
can you tell us how this doctor was able
to do this I mean this is wild this is
an enormous step and what the doctor did
was she took the sperm out of a man and
took it out of the semen and put it
together with an egg this is in vitro
fertilization and then when it made an
embryo he put in this thing called
CRISPR that's able to surgical precision
change one of the three billion letters
of the DNA code and he changed the code
for the HIV receptor for the AIDS
receptor in the cells and then that
embryo was put into a woman so is this a
process able to eliminate HIV because
it's being promoted that way well in
this study they when you edit those
receptor yes you can eliminate HIV but
in these two twins only one of them had
it fully taken out the other one had it
partially taken out but at the same time
it raises the risk of death of flu and
increases the rate of getting West Nile
virus so it's not a perfect treatment
and the problem is there's a lot of our
target affects this enzyme is
promiscuous even though it could change
one letter it happens to maybe change
other things in the DNA so we don't know
any of the unintended consequences yet
obviously this raises a lot of ethical
questions this is banned this process
here in the United States do you ever
see this actually being possible amongst
US doctors but to me this is an
experiment on children right these were
parents the fathers actually had a HIV
themselves and the mothers did not and
then they consented them on the consent
it said HIV vaccine it didn't said gene
editing experiment this is something we
can get rid of inborn errors of genetic
disease potentially but a lot more
science needs to be done it is
way too premature to put it in kids
because we're not gonna know the answer
for 10 20 30 years whether it worked
this is a subject we clearly will be
talking about going forward we've been
talking about CRISPR for the past two
years what can you tell us about this
doctor well this is a doctor who trained
in the United States and then went to
Europe you know there are CRISPR studies
ongoing now in the United States but we
do that in adults to treat a disease
this isn't past generation to generation
once you hit what we call the germline
the DNA of a child it then is passed to
the next generation the next so these
changes are permanent huge changes in
the world of science we'll be hearing
more from this doctor as he speaks at a
conference in Hong Kong but great to
hear you this morning talk about it
thank you dr. a thank you